valorent roster shakeups have made the
any competitive scene look rather
different now that the challenger's open
qualifiers are behind us some of them
make total sense others are a bit
unexpected and one move might just see
the return of some former kings we'll
see about that let's get into it
hey everyone it's elizabeth i've
officially tested negative for covid but
i'm still positively the baddest [ __ ]
of the score esports i saw all of your
comments so thank you for all your
support but the best way you can support
me is by liking subscribing and hitting
that notification bell remember the time
i said i had a lot of trouble keeping up
with all of the roster changes in n a
and there have been so many different
roster shake-ups honestly been kind of
hard to keep track of and it's literally
what i am paid to do well i saw a
comment basically calling me out so i
decided yeah i'll make it an entire
video i guess it's not doing her job now
[ __ ] i was watching the open qualifiers
these past few weekends and i thought to
myself i don't recognize half of these
rosters so i decided to make a video
about it the first one i know is of
course the one y'all cannot shut up
about sentinels the 2021 masters
reykjavik champions roster is no more
with zombs leaving the team to be
replaced by kenpecki who came over from
a crew zom had been a part of the team
since the very beginning over two years
ago and he had some thoughts about his
situation i'm pretty sure the team knew
i wasn't the problem just like
picking up someone else for like
literally no reason like shaz literally
messaged me like saying that wasn't the
problem and we just needed to change
something like his exact words other big
news was raucous returning as sentinel's
head coach the position he held during
champions last year the champions run
famously didn't go great and they
haven't really been doing well since
they didn't even qualify for 2022
iceland but they've had some time to
regroup and they've decided to get the
band back together shazam even said on
stream that he bugged raukus every day
for two weeks about his situation it's
hard to tell if they'll achieve their
former success but qualifying for the
group stage of stage two after beating
kenpecki's former team is a pretty good
start in case you weren't sure how that
went here's a highlight
trying to combo that with the fault line
nothing will connect tens with the
opposite through the spoke
and it's just business as usual at the
moment i should say as usual but it's
business from a year ago for sentinels
and giovanni
of course everyone loves to hate the
heroes so when sentinels were knocked
down to the lower bracket the most
recent qualifier people said they were
washed when they qualified people got
real quiet well mostly
you can't please everyone especially in
valorant all right moving right along we
have hunter thieves and the massive
roster shovels that got everyone talking
they overhauled their staff and almost
their entire team sean garris and mike's
have signed on as coaches with ddk as
general manager while stellar will bang
and derek have been brought in to join
asuna the only remaining member of the
first strike roster jc stanley was let
go from 100 thieves and some pretty
weird circumstances according to his
recent whitlonger he said he was quote
told by someone with hundred thieves
that the plan was to sign me after vct
was told post vct that everything we
were doing was for the long term was
even asked if i'd be willing to main
ingl which i'm fully fine with they kept
reiterating how much they liked me and
how flexible i was he also said nobody
individually did him wrong and the whole
thing was just unlucky fortunately
though he has found a place on gen g and
may nadeshot feel the effects
immediately
okay we're just running it down
yo
oh
my
god jc stanley
send them a golf shirt this guy's insane
this boy is on a revenge tour
oh my god [ __ ] and i think i'm about to
have an aneurysm that was so disgusting
according to shawn garrison dbk ethan
really couldn't fit on this newer roster
but he has found a home at nrg
at the expense of android ethan was
announced to be on the roster a literal
week before the first open qualifier
started which made it pretty hard for
android to find a new home to compete
with and his search continues at the
time of writing but for energy the move
looks like it worked out considering
they qualified hunter thieves qualified
and truly were looking better every
single time they played they were
working well together and were fragging
out where it counted they only dropped
one map the second qualifier tsm did a
little roster switch earlier this year
but most recently wardell and alecko
parted ways with the team and have been
replaced by gmd and seven this iteration
from the roster qualified for stage two
after defeating hundred thieves in the
lower bracket of the first open
qualifiers the last fight against
hundred thieves was grueling with three
maps played and one map going to
overtime but tsm came out in pretty
convincing fashion tsm is a team that
has really really impressed me and
honestly surprised me this open
qualifier i'm not the member of the team
that is a fan of tsm that titles sew it
onto the danny burke but the way tsm
played had our co-workers talking about
how good they looked they did a nice
little transformation revealing their
new roster on april 27th and then
qualified with the new trio joining
dicey and me i mean baby bae
i mean i am definitely the one that
dropped 83 kills against virtuoso
listen if y'all won't let the bit die i
won't either
or is it a bit so a lot of these roster
changes seem to pay off i'm someone who
always cautions against the sentiment of
he's dead weight cut him
but i'm also someone who looks at the
facts seven of the eight teams that made
it through the open qualifier had some
sort of change the only team that didn't
was lg there are teams that didn't make
it through like knights in version one
that didn't change anything but there
are teams like nyfu and gen g that did
make changes and did not qualify an
example of this is when i saw knights
lose to ghost gaming i didn't see a lack
of individual skill or error i saw a
team-wide lack of adaptation in-game in
my opinion the move wouldn't be to
remove someone from the current roster
lg is a team that had no roster moves
and still qualified when i talked to
moose after stage 1 playoffs when they
lost moose told me that he wanted to
work on the team's map pool and how they
played sure we need to build our map
pool uh
because right now we have like one maybe
two maps that we're really comfortable
on
so we for sure that's our main focus and
then just like building more chemistry
more time playing uh and actually
practicing instead of just match match
match match match preparing for a team
for a match like
we're not really
practicing to get better right now we're
kind of just
preparing at all like all of our
practices preparation in this open
qualifier lg won at least one game of
the six individual maps they played in
stage one playoffs five individual maps
were played and out of the seven only
two were one while they still heavily
favor bind growth has been shown without
any sort of roster moves just time and
work to be fair they did play more games
as open qualifier but they still won
more so after all this what does this
mean it means we need to treat these
things delicately if roster moves need
to be made they'll be made but there are
other problems that can exist on a team
losing is a symptom and the roster is
not always the disease remember despite
the fact that we live and breathe it
every day valorent is still a new game
there are new agents and new maps coming
out what it seems like every month and
with literal changes coming out every
month is going to take time for these
teams to prep and construct their
rosters for the long haul a lot of teams
runs have ended for the year after the
open qualifiers concluded so we'll have
to see how these teams will shift
because knowing esports they will
hopefully these roster changes are made
for the better of the team and they
aren't the wrong decisions that will
literally fire someone from their job
this is the manga that a proto from
ghost gaming recommended to me and
let me tell you i'm feeling so many
feelings and emotions it's called a
silent voice um i've almost cried a
bunch now and i'm only in the third i'm
just starting the third volume
um
apparently i'm gonna sob towards the end
so that's exciting but shout out to a
proto um
but yeah
look back there